رمضان ليس موسم سفر لكنه بكل تاكيد موسم
الاستعداد والتحضير للسفر لكن الكثيرين
منكم يخططون لرحلاتهم القادمه بعد رمضان
السفر الفاخر مكلف امر طبيعي باعتبار انها
صناعه مصممه في الاساس لتلبيه توقعات
واحتياجات المسافرين الفارين لكن اليوم
سنتحدث عن اتجاهات مختلفه ايرادات السياحه
الفاخره العالميه وصلت الى 138 دولار
امريكي لكن يبدو ان هناك طرقا لتوفير ربما
الاف الدولارات في الرحله النصيحه الذهبيه
هي التخطيط المبكر لرحلات السفر والمرونه
في مواعيد الحجز كيف يمكن ان يكون السفر
الفاخر ارخص وهل السفر اثناء رمضان فكره
جيده هل نحجز الان لاجازه العيد ام يفضل
الانتظار كل حال ستكون هذه الاسئله محور
نقاشنا في الجانب الاقتصادي او فقره
اقتصادك في رمضان لكن نذهب اولا الى علاء
ودراسه جديده تكشف عن اهتمام ملحوظ
بحجوزات ترانزيت الطويل على كل حال لن
نذهب الى علاء خلينا انا واياك نقراه ههه
نذهب الى هذه الدراسه الاستقصائيه التي
اجرتها شركه ايسلندا للطيران على اكثر من
7000 مسافر كشفت عن اهتمام ملحوظ بحجوزات
ترانزيت استكشاف بلدي اضافي قبل المتابعه
الى الوجهه النهائيه 34% من المسافرين
بغرض الترفيه منفتحون على حج رحلات
ترانزيت او التوقف الطويل وجهات اخرى وهي
زياده قدرها 70% عن 2019 50% من المسافرين
من رجال الاعمال ابدو رغبه في حج رحله
ترانزيت لضرب عصفورين بحجر واحد فمنها
قضاء رحله العمل ومن القيام ببعض الانشطه
الترفيهيه يظهر البحث ان ثلاثه 33% من
المسافرين عبر المحيط الاطلسي مهتمون
بزياره ايسلندا على وجه التحديد في رحلات
الترانزيت لمشاهده ظاهره الشقق القطبي
التي تشتهر به البلاد
دول عده تسهل دخول المسافرين العابرين الى
اراضيها قبل متابعه الرحله اخرها السعوديه
التي اعلنت منحه تاشيره ترانزيت مجانا
للمسافرين عبر المملكه لمده اقصاها
96 ساعه
[موسيقى]
الانترنت وبالتاكيد هنا في الخليج حركه
المطاعم غير عن باقي المدن بسبب التضخم
صار اغلى الناس تفضل تاكل فيه بيتها
بالنسبه للسفر هو نشط حركه السفر من حيث
الناس اللي ترجع الى بلدانها العديد من
الاشخاص يفضلون قضاء هذا الشهر طبعا اذا
يقدرون ياخذون اجازه يفضلون قضاء هذا
الشهر الفضيل مع اهلهم في المنازل ايضا
قطاع السياحه والسفر يعني شاهد بعض النشاط
وشهد ايضا خصوصا المناطق اللي فيها يعني
سفرات دينيه مثل
السياحه الدينيه مثل العمره طبعا هناك صار
هناك
نشاط في هذا القطاع ارتفع عدد التوظيف
ارتفع المداخيل من هذا القطاعها طيب سمر
اليوم في الشهر الفضيل كيف يستطيع الانسان
توفير والاستفاده من روحيه هذا الشهر
بالتوفير وتقليل الاستهلاك حتى يتمكن من
السفر بعد رمضان
شويه دخلنا في البث اللي صار انه للاسف
بالرغم من انه شهر رمضان شهر يعني شهر
رمضان الكريم هو المفروض هو شهر يعني عدم
التبذير شهر يعني
ندير بالنا على اخواننا الفقراء والى اخره
للاسف هناك هدر كبير للطعام يحدث في شهر
رمضان في مصر اللي هي تعتبر من الدول يعني
الناميه اللي محتاجه لهذا الطعام 65% من
الطعام التي تم استهلاكه يذهب الى الويس
الى الهدر في شهر رمضان ايضا هناك تزيد
الاستهلاك على الاطعمه مثل الدواجن مثلا
يزيد ب 60% في شهر رمضان على الفواكه
الناشفه على المكسرات بس كل هذه المواد
ارتفعت اسعارها بشكل كبير في شهر رمضان
مما ادى انه العديد من الاسر يعني اليوم
تكلفه الطعام بالنسبه للعديد من الاسر
زادت من 50 الى 100%
فاليوم العديد من هذه البلدان اللي هي
خارج دول الخليج خلينا نقول اللي هي اغنى
نسبيا والاشخاص يقدرون يعني عندهم قوه
شرائيه اكبر العديد من الاشخاص يعني اختفت
العديد من الاطباق من موائدهم هذاك المره
كان عنا تقرير عن الفتوش في لبنان يعني
هذا واحد من الاكلات الرئيسيه على المائده
في لبنان هذا من الاطعمه او من المواد جدا
ارتفعت اسعار مكوناتها الكشري في مصر عشان
الباستا عندك منظمه انيرا المنظمه الخيريه
في لبنان قالت الرئيس التنفيذيه الها انه
البوكس الطعام اللي كانوا يعطوه يكفي لشهر
رمضان للاشخاص المحتاجين ارتفع من 50
دولار الى 150 دولار بسبب التضخم كل هذه
المسائل ادت الى يعني تراجع في الانفاق
وقدره الاشخاص على الانفاق في هذا الشهر
الماضيه شفنا ارتفاع كبير في معدلات
التضخم الى اي ماده اثر هذا على موعد
الافطار وهل قل على الاقل من هذا الطعام
في رمضان لا بالفعل هذا اللي قلناه انه
اللي نواجهه اليوم انه هناك يعني هدر كبير
الاطعمه وخصوصا في بلدان ممكن تستفيد من
هذه الاطعمه مثل ما قلنا مصر 60% من
الطعام ليتم استهلاكه للاسف اليوم يذهب
الى الهدر طبعا كنا نسوي مواد طعام للاسف
بعد ما تخلص هذه الافطار او هذه العزيمه
اليوم كان احد الزملاء يشكو الي من هاي
الشغله يقول يعني للاسف نص الاكل ذبيناه
بالزباله البارحه بعد العزيمه فهنا هناك
تطبيقات عده على الانترنت تاخذ هذا الطعام
منكم وتغلف بطريقه مناسبه وطريقه صحيه
ونظيفه وتوزعوا على على المحتاجين هذا
الكلام ليس فقط في الامارات ايضا في مصر
ايضا في لبنان هناك تطبيقات في كل دول
العالم حتى في اوروبا بالنسبه للجاليات
المسلمه هناك تطبيق اعتقد اسمه اوليو من
اكثر التطبيقات استخداما تاخذ الطعام
الزايد من الاشخاص وتغلفه بطريقه مناسبه
ثم اعاده توزيعه الى المحتاج شكرا جزيلا